you
it's the first sense you use when you're
born one out of every 50 of your genes
is dedicated to it it must be important
right okay take a deep breath through
your nose it's your sense of smell and
it's breathtakingly powerful as an adult
you can distinguish about 10,000
different smells here's how your nose
does it smell starts when you sniff
molecules from the air into your
nostrils 95% of your nasal cavity is
used just to filter that air before it
hits your lungs but at the very back of
your nose is a region called the
olfactory epithelium a little patch of
skin that's key to everything you smell
the olfactory epithelium has a layer of
olfactory receptor cells special neurons
that sense smells like the taste buds of
your nose when outer molecules hit the
back of your nose they get stuck in a
layer of mucus covering the olfactory
epithelium as they dissolve they bind to
the olfactory receptor cells which fire
and send signals through the olfactory
tract up to your brain as a side note
you can tell a lot about how could an
animal sense of smell is by the size of
its own factory epithelium a dog's
olfactory epithelium is 20 times bigger
than your puny human one but there's
still a lot we don't know about this
little patch of cells - for example our
olfactory epithelium is pigmented and
scientists don't really know why but how
do you actually tell the difference
between smells it turns out that your
brain has 40 million different olfactory
receptor neurons so odor a might trigger
neurons 3 427 and 988 and odor B might
trigger neurons 876 and 2 million four
hundred 96 thousand six hundred and
seventy eight all of these different
combinations let you detect a
staggeringly broad array of smells plus
your olfactory neurons are always fresh
and ready for action they're the only
neuron in the body that gets replaced
regularly every four to eight weeks once
those neurons are triggered the signal
travels through a bundle called the
olfactory tract to destinations all over
your brain making stops in the amygdala
the thalamus and the neocortex this is
different from how sight and sound are
processed each of those signals goes
first to a relay center in the middle of
the cerebral Hemisphere and then out to
other regions of the brain but smell
because it evolved before most of your
other senses takes a direct route to
these different regions of the brain
where a contributor flight response help
you recall memories or make your mouth
water but even though we've all got the
same physiological set up
two nostrils and millions of olfactory
neurons not everybody smells the same
things one of the most famous examples
of this is the ability to smell
so-called asparagus pee for about a
quarter of the population urinating
after eating asparagus means smelling a
distinct odor the other 75% of us don't
notice and this isn't the only case of
smells differing from nose to nose for
some people the chemical and roastin own
smells like vanilla to others it smells
like sweaty urine which is unfortunate
because and Rossa known is commonly
found in tasty things like pork so with
the sweaty urine smeller's in mind pork
producers will castrate male pigs to
stop them from making and rest enough
the inability to smell a scent is called
anosmia and there are about a hundred
known examples people with a listen and
Nas mia can't smell garlic those with
eugenol anosmia can't smell cloves and
some people can't smell anything at all
this kind of full and Azmi I can have
several causes some people are born
without a sense of smell others lose it
after an accident or during an illness
if the olfactory epithelium gets swollen
or infected it can hamper your sense of
smell something you might have
experienced when you were sick and not
being able to smell anything can mess
with your other senses too many people
who can't smell it all also can't really
taste the same way the rest of us do it
turns out that how something tastes is
closely related to how it smells as you
chew your food air is pushed up your
nasal passage carrying with it the smell
of your food those scents hit your
olfactory epithelium and tell your brain
alot about what you're eating without
the ability to smell you lose the
ability to taste anything more
complicated than the five taste your
tastebuds can detect sweet salty bitter
sour and savory so the next time you
smell exhaust fumes salty sea air or
roast chicken you'll know exactly how
you've done it and perhaps be a little
more thankful that you can
you